[Music]
all right so we all know that logan paul
and mayweather are fighting yes that's
for sure for sure
it's for sure for sure for sure for sure
it's an exhibition fight though so it's
not a real fight
why are you sad about that rules or
whatever i don't know i just feel like
mayweather is like a legitimate athlete
um and logan paul is not
and they shouldn't be in the same arena
together well what if mayweather is like
i am a legitimate athlete and i haven't
monetized
enough then on a business more money on
it i mean cool like i mean i get that
but i don't know i like to see the sport
for the sport
i'm with you it kind of cheapens it a
little bit but one could argue that
logan paul is a legitimate youtuber and
mayweather
is not a legitimate youtuber he's
cheaper than youtube it's cheaper than
youtube
cheapen youtube you guys are thinking
way
too complicated mayweather hates logan
paul's vlogs and he wants to beat his
ass
now if that's what he was coming in and
he really wanted to [ __ ] his ass up like
if they could build it up the way they
did mcgregor in him
oh dude i would be so invested but i
just haven't really heard much of it
maybe they're real calm about it maybe
this whole other shit's kind of like
in the background but even still for me
personally i would
think it's kind of like like
mayweather's
like lessening his level like he's like
cheapening his brand
so badly but i agree when i look at this
event though i do look at it with two
lenses
one from a sports angle and i'm like oh
this is like blasphemous and
achievement's a sport
but the other side it's from a business
angle
and there is a huge market
for novelty fights right now like
there's even one with two strong men who
have never boxed
it's gonna be a combined like 800 pounds
in a ring
we've seen already like ksi logan paul
we've seen
uh jake paul uh knockout nate robinson
so we've seen two old boxers
roy jones unit mike tyson come back i
didn't like it so like from that point
of view
like and just talking about business
there is an appetite so whether that
means the viewers
have low quality taste buds i do i think
i do too
it's just like it's kind of like when a
rich person is so rich they [ __ ] all
the beautiful women now they start
looking at
other freaky [ __ ] because they're like
yeah so this is the freaky [ __ ] i guess
which is like it's true
you want some more freaky [ __ ] so on on
on your note geo about
uh wanting that true hatred that true
like mcgregor versus mayweather like
or khabib mcgregor yeah here's uh
jake paul whoa oh lord doing some [ __ ]
here we go are you telling me if you
recognize
what uh like the characters he's playing
here we go
oh nick who the are you doing take
talking little blind [ __ ] i just stuck
homestead to [ __ ] out of him
little punk bro he facetimed my girl
like i don't know what to do i don't
want to fight him because i'm only good
at jiu jitsu and [ __ ] like i'm blaming
my knee injury because i'm going to do
the damage is that you oh you want a
picture
michael bisping here and jake paul i'm
watching you you [ __ ]
you guys want a picture what do you
think of jake paul versus uh
i think he should fly the mad at nunez i
mean i have a small penis and
i saw conor mcgregor's dick all day long
what up who
is that guy i write my ass with 50
million days
that's great is it true that you play
napoleon and napoleon dynamite yes
i focus more on my gambling addiction
right now he's
desperate let's talk about trump i'm
getting out of the white business i'm
telling you the whiskey is where it's at
fought this little blown kid you got
knocked out in five seconds by jorge
mazvido
do you last longer to fight or longer in
bed he called my wife a four
but he can hold all four of my nutsacks
all right so that's the latest and so
he's trying to get someone to bite
he is trying to he's like sending out
letters to
everyone he's like hey come get me i'm a
genius though yeah
i think so you know what that's what 50
cent did
what did he do do you remember back okay
so the reason why he got so damn big
is because he freaking uh trolled
so many people like in battling and then
he called out so many people talk so
much [ __ ]
he [ __ ] destroyed jaw rules career by
[ __ ] bullying the [ __ ] out of him
yeah
and you know that's really this is
before d12 this is before
like eminem discovered him and then put
him on like he discovered himself by
like being that
but it was in his own game of rap like
in this case like
jake paul is trying to get into yeah
he's just trying to find a different way
of getting more viewers and all that you
can't help but see this
and think of a toddler like be like
mommy mommy mommy mommy mommy like
shut up he's definitely drumming out
some drama though what is genius about
him though
this is the ultimate like david versus
goliath story
and you know when you think about like
in terms of the whole spectrum of social
media
it's almost like fighters are in their
own category and they're untouchable and
they're invincible because
obviously they're going to beat the [ __ ]
out of you yeah and he's like the first
person to go i don't really care about
that
i want to get a fight i want clout and
i'm willing to die to make that happen
he might actually die he might because i
don't know if he catches one of these
like jorge maskeldon
i don't know if he's on his good side or
not but people like nate diaz won't hit
massive
i think they'll catch him on the streets
and beat the [ __ ] out of them you know
the other people they're like i'm a
prize fighter if i don't have the right
paycheck i'm
like connor's smart he might talk a bit
conor mcgregor might throw a dolly at
his face
yeah yeah businessman so like like oh so
one person who didn't call that was
khabib
because we all know khabib will beat
don't fly here
jokes yeah and you'll fly here oh [ __ ]
this guy is but he should call out
khabib 2
and see what happens but there's a side
of it where it's like he's painting this
crazy narrative that's pretty like
genius and ballsy
do you think of with the khabib stuff
because didn't he like
say that he will no longer fight because
his dad passed yes do you think this
would professionally i know this could
be a loophole where it's like i'll still
beat your ass because it's not
professional cause i'm sure if you slap
him on the streets he's gonna kick your
ass
true he's not gonna be like oh that's my
last fight
damn this is what i'm confused about i
thought logan paul was canceled
what happened all these years he people
were never cancelled he resurrected his
career as a boxer wait is he the one
with the suicide forest
yeah yeah logan paul logan paul's the
one with that [ __ ] vlog with the
suicide body
just recently saw a headline that he's
getting sued for that or something
really yeah after all these years i
didn't yeah wow
he has a lawsuit on his hands did he
like did he ever leave the public eye
you know like yeah i mean for a short
story
he was using that still as like a leg up
right to get more views
for sure i mean he's got a good team you
know like he never lost views he lost
some subscribers but his videos still
gained more [ __ ] all the time he's
definitely a lot more humble now too i
think that experience changed his
branding i mean whether or not he
changed it changed him or not
like i don't know but his branding is
definitely a lot more he realized where
the line was he was like all right
suicide let's take
one step his brother doesn't seem to
know where the line is his brother is
definitely the crazier one so a little
back story to what uh
uh jake paul is doing here uh with the
whole toilet paper throwing he actually
found dylan danis outside his house and
threw
and chucked uh toilet paper uh uh jake
paul and his team chucked toilet paper
from the back of a truck
at dylan dana's wow and that because he
looked kind of like a stunt though
but i don't know i can't i can't tell
maybe and then like they were both in on
it like
dalen danis was in on it yeah because it
was dylan danis while he was on brendan
shaw's show
oh when it happened so it was like did
how easy is brendan to like
text jake or like how convenient is all
of that you know so and then to that
note too
uh jake paul called dylan danis's uh
uh girlfriend and actually facetimed her
and then like posted about like how like
hey hey dylan come get your girl back or
whatever and like basically
you know trying to cause some sort of
like you know love triangle
drama thing and trying to get a fight
with dylan or mcgregor or
anything with a girlfriend i don't think
so no no the girlfriend was uh
she came out on on her ig saying like
like it was an unexpected call and
she like was gagging or whatever and
like just like catching
grossed out at the fact that um why is
she gay
i literally gagged and like basically
she didn't like the fact that she got
called and
is being used as a pawn in jake paul's
like drama
he's trying to be like tupac yeah
exactly you know
the why the the famous quote that's why
i [ __ ] your [ __ ] you fat [ __ ]
when you did hit him up for biggie
smalls that's because
during our time that was for faith evans
faith evans was trying to get in between
the two and say hey let's just chill
this out right and then she talked to
tupac and then
tupac used as an opportunity to
conspire some [ __ ] and and ruffle some
feathers between that relationship
because they were together so he's like
that's why i [ __ ] your [ __ ] you fat
[ __ ] she stayed with me
in la ah so if you know the story
that's the drama i'm telling you like a
historian i like it
you should you should actually tell
hip-hop stories as a historian
that's that'd be pretty cool with those
glasses that's why i [ __ ]
your [ __ ] you fat [ __ ]
yeah and so then this is what logan paul
has to say about his brother's antics
and uh dana white also responded to
jake paul by saying like never in a
million years zero percent chance you'll
ever get to fight mcgregor or
in the ufc he said maybe amanda nunez
though i meant yeah exactly maybe
amanda is a beacher [ __ ] his ass i would
love to see that here's logan paul
now he's pissed off dana white yo oh
he's been going real hard
so hard on dana white and now dana has
like grouped us together which
which sucks which sucks
bro i love dana white i love dana white
i
love the ufc and now dana's mad at me
because
he thinks we're the same person i saw
the meme but i wanna do a ufc fight one
day like i'm not saying now like you
know let me get my skills up
uh so what do you have to say today okay
they're they're retracting the contract
they were about to send that yeah
hey take me back i'm not jake please bro
he's giving me tickets to go to
ufc fights before like [ __ ] [ __ ] he just
ruined a relationship
all of them because he called i love
conor mcgregor
so yeah what do you guys think about
these these paul brothers trying to get
into ufc so i think boxing's one thing
right i think it's genius i think it's
all planned in the background
i really i really do think it's genius
and they have their own different antics
uh brandon schaub was interviewing
interviewing uh logan paul and he's like
what's the end game for all of this and
then he pretty much says
are you going to end up fighting jake
and then that's when logan was like
now you're asking the right questions
because i think ultimately it's
they're going to go up and fight
everyone right win or lose they win
because they're destined to lose so it's
a win-win situation then at the end
they fight each other two brothers
that's like the biggest mastermind like
narrative
you know sibling rivalry at the highest
so i'm like that's [ __ ] crazy and you
know how [ __ ]
brilliant dana white is that like he is
still conducting us
ufc fights during a world pandemic like
he's about
the w like he just wants to win so the
fact that he's getting with
two top-tier influencers and then
orchestrating some [ __ ] in the back like
it just only makes sense
you know like how many people now are
involved in the ufc drama because these
two guys are part of it like it's
i'm involved but they're ruining the
ethics of martial arts i hate it
that's the part of me that that's the
part how dare they [ __ ]
take my [ __ ] culture and ruin it
don't you [ __ ] dare
as a kung fu practitioner in your youth
don't you feel like they just
molested the [ __ ] out of something that
used to be so
awesome and sacred that's how that's how
i feel like there's a problem thank god
for cobra kai bringing back karate dude
real martial i [ __ ] hate that show
why i was watching it last night that's
why
have you guys watched it season three
past the first episode
why you gotta hate on bring it back real
karate man
now bring me the logan paul's in the
mcgregor's man ah that's what i hate is
that uh
man people don't give a [ __ ] about that
they just care about entertainment and
games because then you watch a real
karate fight it's kind of boring
two guys come out it's not why are you
so respectable
pop pop pop someone gets knocked out no
one really like cheers no one likes
throws up because karate is about
self-development with the art of killing
but you're not meant to ever use those
skills so you spend your life time
learning how to murder the [ __ ] out of
somebody and you never do it yeah
[Music]
you